- ♪ Yo I'm finna kick a verse ♪
♪ That's dope and amazing ♪
♪ About the history
of cultural appropriation ♪
♪ But I could use assistance
to make my case ♪
- Holy cow, it's MC Serch
from 3rd Bass.
- ♪ Appropriation happens
when oppressed culture ♪
♪ Gets co-opted
by a dominant other ♪
♪ So settle back
for this quick recap ♪
both:
♪ By two white dudes in a rap ♪
- ♪ Okay, let's begin
way back in the days ♪
♪ Al Jolson sang ♪ ...
- ♪ Mammy ♪
- ♪ Till he was black
in the face ♪
♪ Then came a guy
who was more embezzling ♪
♪ Than anyone before him ♪
- ♪ El-e-vis Pres-e-ley ♪
- ♪ An icon of appropriating
he was the king ♪
- ♪ That's actually short ♪
both: ♪ For "taking" ♪
- ♪ Steadily snatching
rock 'n' roll ♪
♪ The Rolling Stones
and the Beatles stole ♪
♪ Cher dressed up in a... ♪
- ♪ Half-breed headdress ♪
- ♪ Kenny G
and that smooth jazz ♪
[saxophone solo]
- Oh, hell, yes.
- ♪ Then all the white rappers
came to the game ♪
♪ Same for Marky Mark,
the Beasties ♪
♪ And House of Pain,
and Snow with "Informer" ♪
♪ Any one missing? ♪
- ♪ Stop ♪
♪ Appropriate and listen ♪
I can't help but notice
that someone is missing.
What about the appropriators
3rd Bass?
- ♪ I still got my ghetto pass ♪
♪ Don't make me give you
the gas face ♪
♪ The history of rap
with Justin and Jimmy ♪
♪ Sublime,
Macklemore ♪
♪ And worst of all... ♪
both: ♪ Iggy ♪
♪ Washington Redskins,
Madonna, kabbalah ♪
♪ Coachella hipsters
guzzling iowaska ♪
♪ Cornrows rocked
by Kardashians and Jenners ♪
♪ And Rachel Dolezal ♪
- Oy vey, I remember.
- ♪ Miley Cyrus
and Taylor Swift twerking ♪
♪ White guy saving jazz
in "La La Land" ♪
- Not working.
- ♪ And now it's all meta ♪
♪ And forwards is backwards ♪
♪ Skateboard kids used to dress
like rappers ♪
♪ But now you got rappers
dressing like skaters ♪
all: ♪ Multiple layers
of cultural appropriators ♪
♪ Cultural appropriation ♪
♪ Cultural appropriation! ♪
- Uh, are you sure
we're cool to do this?
- I produced "Illmatic."
I'm good. You?
- Uh